you've got these kinds of asymptotes
which are at the extremities at the far
ends and then there's another kind of
asymptotes vertical ones right vertical
asymptotes got don't come about at the
edges they come around in the middle
they come from domain restrictions right
so let's think about those each in turn
horizontal asymptotes horizontal
asymptotes you think about the
horizontal asymptotes in this way think
about the limit as X approaches these
extreme values right so the limit as X
approaches infinity of this thing like
so okay now in this case because I
crafted it that way and this happens to
be a reasonably simple example because
you can see the denominator is a
quadratic when you experience it out the
top is a linear function so even though
both of them grow and grow and grow as X
gets bigger the denominator is clearly
going to grow much faster much faster
much bigger and so it takes over right
the denominator will be enormous even
though this guy is big the denominator
will always win okay
so if the denominator is always bigger
then what does it happen what happens to
the whole number it's got a prezzie row
so I can say that now what this is
saying here is this is why isn't it the
limit as X approaches infinity of y
equals zero so y equals zero is your
horizontal asymptote there it is right
there okay
so that's good for the horizontal
asymptote since I'm starting to piece
together information now I'm going to
slowly add it to my diagram so on my
Cartesian plane
let's put y equals zero there so it's
sort of like putting together a jigsaw
puzzle y equals zero so there you go so
far so good
don't forget to label your asymptotes by
the way now I want to work out vertical
asymptotes if there are any how do I
work those out vertical asymptotes
where do they come from say it again
Russell okay y equals zero I just okay
yeah I'm looking for the denominator
right so vertical asymptotes come out
from a domain restriction when the
denominator is zero you're in trouble
right you can't you actually can't have
those values so if this becomes zero I'm
in trouble and if this becomes zero I'm
also in trouble so the two x-values that
give me problems are x equals 1 and x
equals negative 2 good so let's let's go
ahead and put those in one
whoops that's possible just like before
you've got asymptotes on there so tell
me what they are labeled them all right
so it's all where you factorized we've
got all our asymptotes that's good now
we're looking for intercepts
just like with asymptotes there's two
kinds of intercepts what are they yeah
good so let's find them one at a time
how do I find x-intercepts yeah let y
equals zero so when y equals zero you
can see the only value you're going to
get that makes it happen
is from the numerator being zero right
which in this case is x equals you've
won so there I'm going to put a nice big
fat dot there at negative one there's my
x-intercept what about y-intercepts how
do I find those let X equal zero so it
looks to me like that's going to be 1
over negative 1 times 2 did you see how
I've got that put 0 into all those spots
that's negative 1/2 how's that look
looking all right those are all the
intercepts so the last piece of
information is now the region's so I'm
gonna grab out another color if you're
just going all in pencil then just shade
what we're going to have a look at here
you can see 1 2 3 these are my factors
ok X plus 1 is a factor X minus X minus
1 is a factor X plus 2 is a factor so
very lightly I'm going to draw them onto
here so X plus 1 is going to look like
this like so X minus 1 is going to look
like this
and then X plus 2 will look like this
okay so you can see by the way have a
look at where my factors change sign
do you notice they have a connection to
the features I already identified see
how this is a spot where this factor
changes sign it goes from negative to
positive and it does that on either side
of the asymptote this factor here also
changes sign around a feature it changes
sign around an intercept and this one
changes around an asymptote as well okay
so these these steps here are all
connected to each other I've got all
three factors on here when I look at the
leftmost part of the domain over here
all three factors are negative so a
negative times a negative times a
negative is negative so wherever my
final graph is going to go it has to
live down here somewhere I switch over
in between here and here here and here
I've got two negatives and a positive so
two negative sense positive is a
positive
in fact what you'll notice if you recall
these are all just going to alternate
from negative to positive the next one's
going to be negative because look
positive positive negative does that
make sense so it's gonna be down here
yeah remember what I'm looking for where
I switch is where the factors change
sign okay so from here to here this
factor change sign heed here this factor
change sign my last one 1 2 3 positive
factors all positive so I'm up here now
ok question
you can't do that that's fine somebody
in values is actually very very similar
in terms of what you're doing to what I
just did in some ways I just subbed in
values but I just don't know their
magnitude because for me it's whether
they up or down that's important okay
alright factorized asymptotes their
intercepts are their regions are their
I'm ready to go I go from left to right
over here you can see I have to stay
down in this corner and I'm constrained
between these two asymptotes so how
would you describe this part of the
shape it sort of looks like a hyperbola
doesn't it so there you go
over on the all the way on the right
hand side I'm going to skip over to here
because it's just as simple you've got
the opposite kind of shape right up in
the top and again you're constrained
between these asymptotes so you've got
sort of like the reversed part like that
the most fun an interesting bit is right
here in the middle so you've got to go
from high to low you know these two
spots you've got to go through so how
would you describe the shape it sort of
looks like a cubic doesn't it it's not I
have to say sort of because it isn't
really a cubic it's clearly not a cubic
but that's the closest shape we know
right so something like this tada
do anything point for scale I think I
have enough information there to provide
scale because you can see here since I
put this information on the reason why
this is important is because this graph
has to be this function it can't be say
this function this function here will
look just like this one except these
values are well this value is different
okay does that make sense it'll be
stretched out but I know because I've
got those two intercepts it has to be
that